I have one heckler but I wasn't afraid
and as Miss Oakland the City University
Wow that you got to that so fast and
don't do your water during because I
know your game is you're not on Charlie
Rose a man yelled out I was sitting
sitting not even standing on the back of
the car waving and he goes you're short
I thought well a newsflash yeah I know
and B can us out of a better heckle I
typically get like shut up you annoying
tour or your smelly hole is like a fish
market and you get that yelled at you
that's yes but what's funny is I
sometimes will get it from gay audiences
as an endearment like maybe though
you're my favorite smelly gash to which
I say thank you and I'm very throw LGBT
as you are as well of course but my
guess would be like Brava diva that's
the difference my gays are like fierce
stinky holes love your gash and and you
know what that is that I do if a street
guy said that to me by the way I'd be
livid so tonight when you're on stage
should I go I love you stinky [ __ ] yep
you think anyone will know it's me I
think if you sing it they might know
it's you I love you you stinking [ __ ]
anybody you make it sound beautiful
thank you that's good that's enough
what's your cup say my cup says lol oh
my god
our oMG what is the red wine Oh a pot
water a thing